so as a filmmaker i would say to you
use the audience's imagination
you don't necessarily have to show
everything
how can indie filmmakers compete with
hollywood
the way that indie filmmakers can
compete with hollywood is on the level
of ideas
because there are ideas that hollywood
is gutless to explore
you will never be able to compete with
hollywood necessarily on a budget
standpoint
marketing money
having said that there are so many more
things at your disposal as an indie
filmmaker that you didn't realize
whether it comes to talent
and asking someone who would bring money
to a project
who knows who that actor might be who is
like
you know you know
maybe sitting around works three months
of the year and the rest of the time is
playing dungeons and dragons
not a joke there's a whole group of
hollywood actors that play dungeons and
dragons might not be a bad thing to
learn
but
there are more things at your disposal
than you would realize so i would say
focus on casting
focus on making the film because there's
really no excuse for an indie filmmaker
because equipment is so inexpensive i
mean
you know
[Music]
i almost look good with the cameras
being used right now
but and these cameras are not
particularly expensive to rent and or
purchase
so on that level make sure that you have
that covered but the way
indie film competes with hollywood is
with ideas
and then what happens is those ideas
will be ripped off by hollywood
because that's
how that
cycle works now that's fine
if they hire the person to do that i
mean sam raimi arguably if you look at
the evil dead series the original evil
dead film
evil dead 2 dead by dawn and the evil
dead 3 that that um
he's basically remaking the same movie
over and over again with a big budget i
don't have a problem with that because
it's sam raimi doing it let him do it
that's great
and and those movies hold up they're
really fun the evil dead films with
bruce campbell
which have amazing commentary tracks if
you can track them down very useful
films from from sam raimi's early career
but where i think indie film competes is
ideas so here's what you do
don't do what hollywood is doing because
you can't do that
on a budget scale what you can do
is explore ideas that hollywood would
not have the guts to do
that hollywood is constrained by
checklists that they must always have in
a big hollywood movie
indie filmmakers are not burdened by
that checklist
and you have to be fearless when it
comes to how you may be perceived on
social media
right
fearless
stop caring what other people think
move
full force with your creative vision and
that's not something that if you look
work for a major studio and you make a
movie with budget and concerns that i
think comes with burden
i mean i've
you've heard the stories time and again
of
of the the burdens that come with
or the the creative shackles that come
with making a movie for a major studio
you
have complete creative freedom and you
need to exercise if you're not
exercising it why are you making it
indie just just pitch it to hollywood
and let them give you the money and move
on but if you're going to make a small
indie movie
you better be willing to explore some
ideas because
it's underestimated
and under used
the audience's imagination
give you an example a throwaway line
from star wars i know star wars comes up
okay
um
uh grand moff tarkin walks in the room
darth vader walks the room they they and
they they're having a council meeting
right
on the death star
and he talks about the emperor has wiped
away the imperial senate they'll not be
a concern for us i'm not quoting it
correct directly but that's the basic
line well one i'm an audience member one
who are all these evil men in this room
right
this
is already scary secondly wait there's
an emperor of the galaxy and there's an
imperial senate who is this emperor of
the galaxy there was an imperial senate
why were they wiped away
and the the thing is is that hollywood
has become so used to the fact that they
can just do anything
why don't we just show that right so we
can show this well ultimately when we
finally saw the imperial senate in the
prequels it was a little maybe
underwhelming like oh okay that's what
it looks like it looks like a lamps plus
or you know that's weird configuration
of it looks like a giant chandelier
upside down okay weird um in any case
but what i'm saying is is that my
imagination as a kid
was utilized
because characters in the movie talked
about off-screen events
happening
and i think that that is
a
device that is underused
so as a filmmaker i would say to you
use the audience's imagination
you don't necessarily have to show
everything there are different ways for
information to get begotten across and
not just through some news report
right that's the that's the lazy go-to
is a news report on the news you know
they call it
the device they call it captain
narrative where it's like somebody that
just sort of explains the narrative to
kind of catch the audience up with what
events are happening
so my suggestion is try to use parts of
the audience's brain
that
they're not used to using which is their
imagination i think that not only will
you'll engage the audience more get them
to you know whether they physically do
it or metaphorically kind of or they
just sort of lean into the story they're
just sort of
leaning in and and gets them to think
about what the events they're seeing
like oh like this
and also i think it shows respect for
the audience
right it doesn't mean you're not going
to have
your money shots in the film whether it
be something big budget or whatnot but
you know you can expand your world by
allowing the audience to use their
imagination and convey information in a
shorthand whether it be dialogue
something that's seen very quickly
i i i
see that less often
in major studio movies and i'd like to
see it used more often in independent
films
you know explore an idea that's never
been
discussed or explored or explored in a
way that is new and fresh
that's what i think is the power for an
independent filmmaker you
you need to
really
make sure that those ideas are so
compelling
that if you just
tell someone the idea
they'll lose their minds
it almost sounds like you're referring
again to
the topic of puzzles
right yeah because you know maybe
showing a crime that you we don't see
the crime that was committed but we hear
about it from different people's points
of view that's that could be one aspect
of making the audience guess
yeah absolutely it it gives the audience
something to do because i mean look
what's the number one thing you want to
do in a movie you want how do you want
the audience to feel you want the
audience to feel that they care about
what's going to happen next and what's
going to happen next right and you're
leading them along and you're giving
them crumbs but not all of it right and
give them some work to do
and i feel like the the reason that the
original star wars films
hold up the original trilogy is because
it gave the audience something to do
there's so much of what's seen in the
original star wars trilogy that's never
explained
you know
that that are such clever throwaway
ideas
that are in the background that just
spur the imagination and that's hardly
done these days i mean if anything
audiences are spoon fed and
overexplained things are over explained
to them because studios think that
audiences are stupid and that's not the
case
audiences are much more savvy these days
they're way far ahead which is why so
much content is like meh it was okay
i can't tell you how many times i've
walked out of a big hollywood movie and
forgotten it by the time i walked in my
car
like a big action movie where you're
like well none of that really mattered
what were the stakes
i didn't it seems like i've seen it
before
i feel like indie film has the freedom
to
go a few layers deeper and
explore new ideas and engage the
audience with it
so
please more of that